it's a relatively cushy job that seems
to pay pretty well but that doesn't mean
being a movie star isn't hard work
multimillion-dollar productions rely on
an actor's ability to tonight so there's
a lot of pressure for them to do a good
job and not everyone is great under
pressure an actor will occasionally for
whatever reasons to get their line and
they all flub in different ways they
also deal with the embarrassment
differently and oftentimes hilariously
here are some famous actors who were
caught messing up their dialogue
Laurence Fishburne Bartram humor is the
great human equalizer be at the young
and the old the rich and the poor or the
smart and the dumb both oscar-nominated
and non oscar-nominated actor alike can
get behind a good but reference which is
precisely what happened on the set of
the 2016 science fiction film passengers
in a very wordy scene Laurence Fishburne
who plays the spaceships chief deck
officer briefs supposed to be
hibernating passengers Chris Pratt and
Jennifer Lawrence on the cross movement
he ends up giving us a lesson in space
Anatomy instead Jupiter Uranus and then
Along Came Bradley Cooper messin up
lines will usually cause an actor to
break character laughs lightly cursed
get back to their mark and give it
another try but some actors are just too
cool for that
maybe not that cool but hangover actor
Bradley Cooper can give us a master
course on what to do when you flub your
lines during a rooftop monologue what
happens here tonight may as well never
happen there that never happens
just fake it till you make it even if
that means that you have to speak in
gibberish Christina Applegate in Will
Ferrell and Adam McKay's anchorman a
silly spoof of a horrendously sexist 70s
workplace Christina Applegate plays the
glass ceiling shattering news anchor
Veronica Corningstone she faces open
hostility from other members of the
Channel 4 News team including sports guy
champ kind played by David Koechner and
reporter Brian Fantana played by Paul
Rudd inside source tells me that the FBI
has been called in to aid in this
ongoing investigation who I am II it
would be hard for anyone to act under
those circumstances Paul Rudd the comedy
films of Judd Apatow maintained an
almost impossible balance between strong
earnest characters and over-the-top
ridiculousness the 40 year old virgin as
it's serious in the heartfelt moments
but it's during one of these the Paul
Rudd slips up while pronouncing the name
of a famous painter if you love trash
you can't do this and you gotta finish
waxing your chest cause you look like
Advantix disclaiming yeah sorry Ben
Stiller it seems like pretty much every
romantic comedy ever made has some
variation of the don't get on that plane
speech and the 2004 Ben Stiller Jennifer
Aniston film Along Came Polly is no
exception when it comes time for Stella
ton Valley's true feelings you can't
quite remember the specifics of this
particular romantic monologue you go off
to Tanzania or Cincinnati or wherever
you're going you get to you
Timothy Dalton you've got to be smooth
in order to play James Bond and Timothy
Dalton succeeded at being the ultra cool
super spy for two movies back in the
late 1980s years later he took on the
role of the villain in the Simon Pegg
cop spoof Hot Fuzz betraying his
double-oh-seven image of calm and cool
style of security footage where was a
mother kid I'm sorry well that's all
mottely amusing what happens next
was golden don't roll it okay
Mila Kunis in Forgetting Sarah Marshall
Jason Segel plays peter bretter
who is as you can probably guess trying
to forget his old girlfriend Sarah
Marshall you don't want you the Plain
Jane should go back to where she came
from that is a mother of mine Peter
beretta retreats to a resort where he
gets over Sarah with the help of a
resort staffer played by Mila Kunis
initially Kunis's character has to call
him mr. beretta but she just can't seem
to get a ride Oh mr. Brenner mr. brain
what I said better
Rob Riggle in the real world it's pretty
absurd the one grown man does dare down
another grown man and tell him that he's
going to hurt him it's doubly absurd to
have to do this with the comedy legends
like Will Ferrell let's take this I'm
going to drive it into your temple
prepare yourself for a fight a fight the
time I don't want that unlike Will
Ferrell we definitely want more Harrison
Ford the explosion of the first Death
Star is supposed to be a moment of
triumph for Han Solo and the rebel
forces followed by celebration and
exultation all that celebrating is
supposed to be followed by some lines
but Harrison Ford totally blanks on what
those lines are supposed to be ha ha ha
but eating your mic is definitely one
way to go rogue thanks for watching
click the lubricon subscribe to our
YouTube channel plus check out all this
cool stuff we know you love to
[Music]